Vladimir Putin's re-election is certain.
Don't waste your time looking at his
carefully-scripted but sterile campaign
for clues to Russia's future. Instead,
look at the $327 billion dollar defense modernization
program that Putin signed in Sochi on
November 27th after a non-stop, four day
session with Russia's top military brass.
This in a country where personal incomes
have been going down for four years,
growing poverty is a key problem, and
social protests are up 56 percent. But
that's exactly the point:
Russia is effectively at war. When he
signed the defense modernization program,
Putin called on all Russian enterprises –
private or state – to be ready to switch to
military production "in a time of need" as
he put it in order to, again a quote,
"efficiently neutralize" external threats.
The message is clear:
Putin is a wartime president, and wartime
presidents are not to be replaced so
long as the war is going on. And Putin,
his propaganda machine, and his generals
will make sure that it is, and gets
hotter by the day.
So what do you think will happen in Russia after Vladimir Putin's re-election in March 2018? Let us
know in your comments. Also, let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds, and be
sure to like and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI.